making a movie can take years so it's no
wonder Disney filmmakers often break up
the tedium by adding in jokes and easter
eggs into movies for their own
entertainment here's a look at some of
these hidden Disney moments almost no
one notices more cowbell Disney one
critical accolades for its thoughtful
live-action adaptation of The Jungle
Book which features Christopher Walken
as the voice of King Louie a giant
fearsome eight coming in one scene man
cub Mowgli is deposited in front of all
the human treasures Louie and his
minions have accumulated mowgli is
intrigued by one item in particular and
he picks it up and shakes it a cowbell
unless you somehow miss the significance
that's a clear reference to walkins
enormously popular mm Saturday Night
Live sketch in which he plays a music
producer in the studio making Blue
Oyster cult's don't fear the reaper and
who persistently demands more cowbell
looks like he finally got it guess what
I got a fever and the only prescription
is more cowbell Rudyard Kipling's Jungle
Book shout out the jungle book movie is
not only faithful to the original book
it also gives it a subtle nod Mowgli has
two notable scars the one on the right
of his chest forms a lowercase R while
one on his left shoulder resembles a K
those aren't accidents RK are the
initials of Rudyard Kipling who in 1900
wrote the anthology of stories that
inspired the jungle book films canine
crossover the Twilight Bart is a pivotal
moment at 101 Dalmatians in which every
dog in London is contacted for help in
reclaiming all those puppies kidnapped
by Cruella De Vil among the dogs who
hear the call Lady and the [ __ ] from
well lady in the [ __ ] on a dark Street
barely concealed in shadow also in the
scene in separate cameos are Lady and
the [ __ ] characters jock the terrier
and peg and bull
Tarzan's familiar teapot upon her
arrival in the jungle miss Porter has to
service laid out with a very nice and
very well known
seht recognize it it's the exact same
pattern sported by mrs. Potts and chip
from Beauty and the Beast it only
appears on screen for a split second but
it made enough of an impression to be a
real-life Easter Egg as well at Tarzan's
treehouse in Disneyland a replica of the
tea service sits on a table and it's
movie accurate down to the Beauty and
the Beast inspired teapot and cups big
hero 6 meets frozen big hero 6 was
released in early 2014 right on the
heels of Disney's wildly popular frozen
unsurprisingly the movie is loaded with
frozen inspired bits for example when
hero and robot baymax take flight over
the city Olaf the snowman can be spotted
an aerial shot also shows off San
fransokyo Bay and harbor where a ship
from arendelle is ported and when the
hero crew makes a permanent headquarters
out of the wealthy Fred stately home the
robot baymax tries out his weaponry and
blows away a statue a stone rendering of
the villainous Prince Hans from frozen
justice oh if only there was someone out
there who loved you
what a jerk princess party Elsa's
coronation attracts some pretty powerful
people from all over the realm and
beyond visible among the guests are
Rapunzel and Flynn Rider from tangled it
doesn't end there a scan of a crowd
scene at the coronation reveals Tiana
from The Princess and the Frog got an
invite to the only one missing is Olaf
but that's probably just as well
so fishes heat oh but don't touch it
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Disney injo
is your favorite